all right moving on to weather sherry's
off today your most accurate weather now
forecast beginning with this view
from our camera on top of the red rock
resort way out of the west side of town
a little bit hard to tell
but the palm trees not moving a whole
lot you get the idea we have this
blanket of cloud cover after making it
to 59 yesterday
that's kind of what we're expecting for
later today we think the clouds will
start to roll out of here the official
temperature is 48 let's see what's
happening in your neighborhood
got a couple of readings at 50 that
would be henderson and along the strip
48 we've got a bunch of those downtown
uh sunrise mountain
a little bit cooler out at the lakes
there's another 48 for mountains edge
49 up in centennial hills that includes
providence and sky
canyon seven hills and anthem you're in
the mid 40s bottom line
it is going to stay on the cloudy side
today but really the only chances for
precipitation are going to be up in
lincoln county calienda you're at 29
right now
and mount charleston may get a couple of
additional snowflakes as well
amargos at 54 death valley right now at
55. we
are going for again a 59 that's the same
temperature we topped out at yesterday
that's close to normal
but the current temperature well our
current temperature is 48 we've been
down to 47.
that's well above the normal low because
of all of that cloud cover
so here's what's going on we have this
area of low pressure banging another
bunch of storms into the pacific
northwest well down here we're just
getting those passing clouds
and we will have more reports throughout
the morning and show you the snow that's
falling over along the east coast
here is your eight day forecast up to 64
tomorrow 65 wednesday but going to be
very windy
slight chances for sprinkles super bowl
sunday looks great in las vegas mostly
sunny and 63.
we are keeping those overnight lows